why would you use CG to make Patrick
Stewart look younger an actor who looked
exactly the same 20 years ago as he does
today how are you gonna reconcile this
now that first class came out and showed
us that Charles and Eric parted ways as
young men I mean I know everyone wants
to forget this movie but you can't just
ignore shit that happened it and if
you're gonna bring back the old cast for
Days of Future past
okay levitating all the cards and the
lawnmower but why bother with the water
coming out of the hose also Shirley
Stanley could have made a better
appearance than this phallic cameo King
Brett Ratner these decorative or de
jeans parents serve Charles and Eric tea
with hard-boiled eggs totally impossible
war simulation revealed cliche cheat all
so Brett Ratner rips off the holodecks
from Star Trek The Next Generation nice
throw
yeah did Colossus actually throw
Wolverine or did he just simulate
throwing it why wouldn't Wolverine just
smash into the wall of a simulator if
Colossus actually threw it oh so this is
the building where Iceman cheats on
rogue with Kitty's kitty this movie came
out in May of 2006 but claims to be set
in the not-too-distant future which
means that the super-smart doctor
character is really diving into an
article in this magazine from October
2005 which has to be at least two or
three years old if not more Raven I
asked you a question I don't answer to
my slave name
yes mystique please tell us about your
slave days I think everyone would be
interested in hearing how your
experience compared to American slavery
from 1619 to 1865 whoa whoa mystique
this is the 21st century no one speaks
Latin anymore
when an individual acquires great power
the use or misuse of that power is
everything what about responsibility I
think you're forgetting the
responsibility that turns us into
tyrants over our fellow man but Einstein
said
I thought that perhaps you might take my
place someday say when I die halfway
through this movie for instance who
builds a lab on Alcatraz Island who does
that
I'll tell you who Brett Ratner that's
who this guy is still an asshole my kid
will surely try and rescue mystique as
they've said several times in the movies
so let's make sure our awesome new
mobile prison is inside a
tractor-trailer entirely made out of
metal I'm listening
Cyclops is a dick to a quantified scene
does not contain Phoenix style lap dance
I can't see a damn thing
I can take care of that jeez why didn't
you just do this before he landed the
plane in this Adele Jean Grey is the
only class 5 mutant I've ever
encountered AB movie speaks about mutant
grading systems as if the previous
movies have ever mentioned that before
also class 5 sounds good but what are
the criteria Professor X says he's only
encountered one so how could Magneto be
better at manipulating methyl or
mystique changing into people or Xavier
himself at getting into people's heads
this grading system sounds like total
bullshit
cancer I hope it's cancer instead of
admiring angel's wings the doctor lady
is instead admiring the overhead lights
or the ceiling or something if your
mutant powers angel wings glass loses
its ability to cut you seems pretty
silly that multiple man would divide
into six copies of himself right after
coming out of his cell but then again
the movie never even made an attempt to
show us there were other prisoners or
what they could do until this moment in
time so I guess they had to play catch
up on what these assholes could do King
Brett Ratner so when gene killed Scott
at alkali Lake the professor could sense
her power but when she's making the sexy
time with Wolverine the x-man can sense
a damn thing
also Wolverine somehow didn't learn to
never stick your dick in crazy
whoa Jean Grey not only turned into the
Phoenix but she also turned into xenia
onatopp I guess no one is monitoring
Jean during her coma slash telekinetic
energy cocoon recovery nobody said it
was Xavier's school for gifted nurses it
may be tonight so let's go by car
instead of taking the jet also it's
parents play in the street with your kid
day in this neighborhood yourself but I
can help you to lie
patrasche yeah well I guess you don't
hire juggernaut for his brain because he
throws wolverine into the very house he
was supposed to be guarding him from
apparently no one in the whole
neighborhood gives a shit about all the
commotion happening at the gray house
geez father figures leave no need to be
a pussy
do make up you're my hero nobody gives a
signal of any kind but everyone still
rises in unison love triangle girl for
Iceman conveniently mrs. snow and ice
skating
I guess Bobbi's going with the old
Groundhog Day courtship routine and it
seems to be working
geez familiar story am i right guys the
jealous girlfriend you make one little
fountain into an ice skating ring for
another chick and suddenly she's packed
and ready to go
I wanna touch people Logan said every
pedophile ever hug a handshake a kiss a
handjob
anal also couldn't she just buy a Trojan
body condom like lieutenant Frank Drebin
did in the Naked Gun think about what I
said Murray nope that's her slave name
all these super-powered humans in the
forest mean you mean to tell me they
didn't play one game of baseball the
twilite lie to me hey Pete she yeah she
took off that dude did not see that only
Wolverine did also hey what should we
have the super strongly mutant do while
he's walking by Bobby to help
demonstrate that he's super strong I
know he could be carrying a giant TV
brilliant and there are a ton of people
who hate The Cure at this rally they
must have never been in love on a Friday
say to know the cure this is a class 1
mutant I presume I'm gonna forget for a
moment that these are supposed to be
mutants with powers and wonder why
magneto decided to give someone or allow
someone to use of cooking bat to guard
the perimeter
I'm sure just keep throwing those spikes
in the same place every time surely what
didn't work 100 other times will
eventually work at some point Magne new
secure cover band has entirely too many
memories perfect condition called Homo
Sapien is this supposed to be like a
Klan rally Marvel crossover check it out
Jamie Foxx's electro has a cameo in The
Last Stand roughly eight years before he
was even cast in the amazing spider-man
2 nothing
despite the fact that no one knows why
the Golden Gate Bridge is collapsing
everyone starts running toward the much
longer route off the bridge no one in
this racial stereotype noticed all the
cars that were smashing into each other
while they took this picture in front of
the Golden Gate Bridge this is cool and
all but it's probably the least
practical way for Magneto's troops to
get to Alcatraz I mean steal a jet for
pete's sake or I don't know a boat
clearly daytime here but then suddenly
nighttime here grow those back is there
a reason why you couldn't dickhead man
the dialogue in this movie just crackles
doesn't it good thing you just happen to
be flying around at this very moment in
time so he could save his father and
teach him a valuable lesson about
mutants in the process yes take cover
from the flying burning car bombs next
to the hazardous chemicals that seems
totally sensible isn't all this just a
little unnecessary I mean can't magneto
just find an aircraft carrier another
section of the Golden Gate Bridge and
send it way up 10,000 feet in the air
and then bring it down and smash
everyone and everything on Alcatraz
Island problem solved right isn't this
one car at a time thing kind of
needlessly weakened also couldn't you
just take Wolverine and Colossus out of
the equation any time he wanted to why
is he just letting them continue to slow
the progress of his attack I mean flick
your finger and send those crisps to
Oakland man storm but I need some cover
it's nice that the real x-men to always
get storms something to do so she feels
valuable to the team movie establishes
that the two people fighting or equally
match which means some total bullshit is
gonna happen before one of them wins
see the darts are left or right here on
Magneto's chest but then they're up and
down here man like some then we'll go to
for some hot beanbag her all these
headlights on this attack where the
bridge was moved started in broad
daylight
so the headlights shouldn't be on and
even if they are like daytime running
lights or someshit
are the cars on that bridge all still
running oh sorry Roca thought you were
gone I'm banging Juno now did they find
a cure for the kid who sucked all the
powers out of the mutants because if
they didn't this school is gonna suck
brett ratner geez does anyone in the
series ever stay dead when Cyclops does
because Cyclops your cities will not be
safe your streets will not be safe you
will not be safe
I want this country to realize that we
stand on the edge of oblivion I want
every man woman and child to understand
how close we are to care
yes what have I done sweet Jesus what
have I done
become a thief in the night become a dog
on the run